mik et tout ça pour le bien de la
planète
et
[Musique]
les journées du patrimoine maintenu
malgré la hausse des contamination du
virus en france le chef de l'état a
appelé ses concitoyens hier à s'y rendre
alors que la france a franchi le cap des
13 mille cas positifs les français
auront peut être eu la chance d'ailleurs
de voir le toulouse
il m'avoue rénové à la feuille d'or à
l'elysée
dans un contexte de polémique en france
l'union européenne a appelé à accélérer
le déploiement de la 5g bruxelles qui a
exhorté les 27 à ne pas prendre
davantage de retards dans le contexte de
crise sanitaire
la commission demande une liste sur les
fait sa mise en oeuvre d'ici au 30 mars
prochain les etats unis accusent de
nouveau la russie de vols d'informations
technologiques lierre dans le minnesota
donald trump a affirmé que les rues son
relais de la technologie
d'administration en baba technologie qui
concerne les missiles supersoniques de
la tenir compte in a répondu que son
pays avait cette technologie bien avant
le mandat de barack obama
[Musique]
et
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france est la
une de l'actualité ce samedi la 37e
édition des journées du patrimoine
maintenu sous restriction dans un
contexte de regain de la pandémie moins
de lieux ouverts au public priés de
respecter les distances des visites
virtuelles de certains sites ou bien d
inscription préalable pour pouvoir
visiter emmanuel macron a rappelé hier
l'importance à ses yeux de ces
journées-là encourager les français à
participer
alors que la france a enregistré ce soir
plus de 13 mille à 400 cas de
contamination alors quel est l'état
d'esprit des visiteurs on les écoute
je pense que c'est ouvert c'est que a
priori les mesures ont été prises et que
mais les dons clairement mais elles ne
sont pas dans le métro elles ne sont pas
dans plein d'autres endroits donc
effectivement je trouve ya un avantage à
cette journée avec cette crise sanitaire
c'est que c'est surtout inscriptions
du coup il n'y a pas la queue on sait
que les barrières j'ai se marier avant
est respecté les distances mise donc on
peut visiter plus avec le respect donc
ses intérêts est ce la distance à
respecter alors je vois pas très bien un
bourreau disons que on est plus de
l'ordre du dix centimètres à 1 mètre
entre les gens ouais bah là en principe
on arrive à respecter après c'est pas
sur trente secondes qu'on va être à
proximité à moins d'un mètre d'une
personne que je pense que je pense que
ça se passe bien quoi a priori doit il
doit y avoir des consignes relatifs aux
qu'ovide et donc il y a des places
limitées ils sont obligés de 2
de d'accueillir qu'un certain nombre de
personnes à l'intérieur donc là comme
vous pouvez voir il ya du monde qui va
devoir faire demi tour et voilà et c'est
notre cas et parmi les monuments qui
ouvrent leurs portes ce week end la nef
de la cathédrale de notre dame de paris
l'occasion pour les guides touristiques
de pousser un coup de gueule aujourd'hui
leur situation reste précaire malgré les
aides promises par l'état
les nombreux serais-tu de cette
profession de guide conférencier ne
permettent pas à tous d'obtenir des
financements
écoutez les guides qui sont auto
entrepreneur ou micro entreprises etc
peuvent en bénéficier du fonds de
solidarité qui entre parenthèses censée
s'arrêter en décembre pour l'instant
comprenez bien que c'est pas en janvier
que le tourisme va reprendre donc il est
clair qu'il va falloir prolonger mais ça
ça va concerner toutes les entreprises
liées au tourisme pas que les guides et
à côté de ça il y a eu la possibilité de
mettre du chômage partiel sauf que ça
c'est pratiquement inexistant pour nous
et la façon de travailler que nous avons
font que nous n'avons pas bénéficier du
chômage partiel et donc pas tous les
guides qui sont salariés ou qui ne
rentrait pas dans le cadre légal du
fonds de solidarité pour l'instant n'ont
rien et ça fait des mois que ça dure
et donc ça c'est problématique et là on
fait un appel pour que ça change
on veut vraiment que nous ne soyons pas
abandonner parce que pour l'instant
c'est la situation et à l'occasion de
ces journées du patrimoine l'elysée a
également ouvert ses portes les français
auront eu peut-être ou auront la chance
de voir le bureau des manuels macron
dans le salon doré
il vient tout juste d'être restaurée
pour la somme de neuf cent trente mille
euros
on le sait gouverner c'est choisir les
priorités quelques oticon en pleine
crise sanitaire économique sociale ou
les suppressions d'emplois la détresse
du personnel soignant des enseignants à
d'une grande partie de la population
sont devenus la norme
il ya quand même certaines priorités
qu'il faut pas oublier ça fait soixante
dix ans que le salon doré du palais de
l'elysée n'avait pas été rénovée c'est
scandaleux
en plus c'est les journées du patrimoine
et il faut bien que les français
puissent avoir le droit de profiter du
luxe et du face de la résidence de leur
président bah oui emmanuel macron le
répète souvent on n'ose pas décidé ces
travaux alors que c'est notre devoir
pas sûr que les gilets jaunes qui
manifestent depuis bientôt deux ans
contre la politique du gouvernement
considère la rénovation du palais de
l'elysée comme un devoir mais bon c'est
pas le sujet au mois maintenant le
président pourra faire ses allocutions
télévisées sans ressentir l'inconfort
que ressent le monarque dont le trône
est devenu quelque peu poussiéreux je
suis désolé c'est important quand on
voit à quel point les éléments revivent
comme les fleurs et les nymphes ressorte
ça s'est complètement transformée à bas
avec quinze mille feuilles d'or de 0,2
microns d'épaisseur ce qui fait environ
390 grammes c'est sûr que ça s'est
transformé
ils ont pas mis un coup de faiblesse ces
gens sont très sérieux ces emplois et ce
savoir faire français permettent de
projeter l'excellence française à
l'étranger
tout à fait d'accord mohammed bin salman
actuellement se ronge les ongles au fond
du couloir terrassé par l'envi en
novembre 2018 alors que des millions de
personnes se mettaient à défiler dans
les grandes villes de france pour les
premiers actes d gilet jaune la première
dame non plus n'était pas laisser mettre
la pression
rénovation du mobilier de l'elysée pour
plusieurs millions d'euros et bien pas
de chez casto la table basse on avait
l'impression que l'elysée était devenue
une forteresse qui se protéger de
l'extérieur on va aller j'ai épuré il
faut de la lumière
c'est vrai qu'il fait un peu sombre et
la vaisselle à 500000 euros pareil c'est
la moindre des choses
on va pas manger dans des assiettes en
carton un dîner d'état c'est pas un
pique nique sur l'autoroute a7
je rappelle quand même que j'ai encore
le temps fort de brégançon y avait même
pas de piscine c'est scandaleux
et même si après avoir eu sa piscine le
président dans un bain de foule admet
préférer la maire c'est son droit
y a que les imbéciles qui ne changent
pas d'avis donc rénover le salon doré de
l'elysée c'est un peu la base du swag
même si ça plaît pas à tout le monde
pas de noms mais je suis pas d'accord
non non non le 130 mille euros at on
sait rien ou 130000 euros
vivement elle est un point à présent sur
les chiffres de l'épidémie ce soir le
nombre de cas positifs qui augmente vous
allez loire nouveau record de
contamination ces dernières 24 heures 13
1498 nouveaux cas 26 morts 58 nouveaux
foyers de contamination identifiés et 89
départements répertoriés en situation de
vulnérabilité modérée ou élevée et pour
en parler nous sommes en direct avec
jean paul stahl infectiologues au chu de
grenoble alpes
bonsoir jean paul stahl merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france comment est-ce
que vous analysez ces chiffres alors il
ya ces augmentations de cas déclarés
1300 4300 près près de mille cinq cents
ou près de 1400 pardon et en même temps
très peu de morts 26 enregistrés ces
dernières 24 heures comment est ce que
vous expliquez cela on va tout
simplement d'abord parce que on n'a pas
encore le nombre de personnes
hospitalisées en réanimation on avait il
ya quelques mois
donc forcément en le nombre absolu étant
plus faible même si le pourcentage reste
quand même le nombre de décès est plus
faible
ça c'est le premier point puis le
deuxième point c'est que on s'est mieux
traiter les malades on et traite plus
précocément en particulier avec des
corticoïdes puisqu'on a bien montré que
maintenant que c'était efficace donc la
prise en charge des patients est
meilleure ce qui explique sans doute le
moins de décès mais enfin il faut pas il
faut pas se contenter de ça il faut bien
constater que l'épidémie est en
augmentation et donc il faut tout faire
pour essayer de la ralentir
c'est ça que les français ont du mal à
comprendre on dit qu logo que l'épidémie
est en augmentation puisque les cas
maintenant sont dépistés en masse et
forcément le nombre évidemment est élevé
mais comment est-ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est plus élevé qu'en mars alors qu'il
n'y avait pas de dépistage là on a du
mal à comprendre
ben c'est que l'augmentation des cas et
supérieurs à l'augmentation des tests
tout simplement
il ya un vrai décalage alors les tests
sont bien entendu responsables pour une
part de cette augmentation des cas mais
pour une part seulement et est donc le
reste c'est lié à une accélération de la
contagion
alors on a aussi du mal à comprendre la
politique du gouvernement les français
sont un peu perdus on voit que les
journées du patrimoine sont maintenus
les métros
ont enlevé leur leurs mesures de
distanciation et les métros sont bondées
à paris et dans le même temps certaines
villes resserre les boulons si je puis
dire de ferme des restaurants plutôt
limite les rassemblements comment
comment est-ce que vous analysez vous en
tant qu infectiologues ces mesures
devraient simplement que l'ensemble du
territoire et pas et pas à la même
enseigne à elle pas à loger à la même
enseigne
le lia certaines villes où la
circulation du virus est bien plus
importante que dans d'autres et donc les
mesures sont plus importantes et ce qui
justifie pour d'autres de ne pas encore
être à ceux à ce stade de contraintes
tout simplement
donc paris n'en fait pas partie a priori
puisque les transports en commun ont
desserré en tout cas les les mesures
belle et les autres villes n'ont pas non
plus de stopper les transports en commun
d'un autre côté il faut bien avoir
conscience que le confinement c'est
quand même l'arrêt de toute activité
économique et sociale et il serait sans
doute pas souhaitable de recommencer cet
exercice donc il faut je crois à faire
appel à la responsabilité des gens les
gestes barrières sont simples ce sont
évidemment des contraintes mais c'est à
ce prix là qu'on évitera 1re confinement
qui serait un désastre économique bien
évidemment est ce que je vais vous poser
une question en tant qu infectiologues
est ce que pour vous ce n'est pas trop
tard on voit que le gouvernement
priorise vous l'avez dit l'économie on a
l'impression que ils laissent faire en
tout cas dans les populations qui ne
sont pas à risque on
on va vers l'immunité collective sans
sens sans dire oh non pas du tout pas du
tout les populations dites à moindre
risque ne se soumettent pas pour
beaucoup aux contraintes
donc ça c'est pas quelque chose qui est
organisée qui est voulu
c'est vécu comme ça et c'est appliqué
comme ça mais l'ensemble de la
population devrait appliquer les mesures
barrières
c'est un problème de responsabilité
envers les autres c'est à dire quand
vous êtes contagieux même si vous n'avez
pas une maladie grave vous pouvez la
transmettre à quelqu'un qui est à haut
risque et éventuellement provoquer des
décès on est dans ce registre là oui
mais alors le gouvernement justement
limite les restrictions on l'a vu hélas
la période de quatorze haine qui est
ramené à sept jours des classes qui
fermait beaucoup et qui finalement
revoit aussi leur politique
on a l'impression que finalement la
population jeunes se dit on l'a vu dans
le reportage d'ailleurs sûr si on est
sur les journées du patrimoine les gens
n'ont pas l'air si inquiet que ça un
ballet des gens sont pas inquiet parce
qu'ils ne voient pas les morts que nous
nous voyons dans les hôpitaux ils ne
voient pas les réanimations il ya il ya
une distance entre la perception
effectivement de tout venant
et puis ce qui se passe réellement dans
les hôpitaux et tant qu'on ne boit pas
on se rend pas compte maintenant la
diminution de la 14è n'a une à une
semaine ça tient simplement compte des
nouvelles données épidémiologiques et de
données scientifiques que l'on a
maintenant tout simplement le de même
que les mesures dans les écoles où on
est maintenant à peu près certain que la
transmission à l'intérieur des écoles et
des enfants vers les adultes est
relativement faible alors il ya aussi
cette politique des tests avec les
nouveaux tests salivaires qui ont été
validés est-ce que ça va améliorer les
choses
parce que pour l'instant
le délai est extrêmement long or le
délai est extrêmement long effectivement
parce que à peu près tout le monde a
accès à un test ou voudraient avoir scac
c'est un test
que l'on soit une personne contact où
que l'on soit vraiment la porteur de
symptômes
il est vrai que les tests les tests
salivaires vont améliorer la rapidité du
résultat mais encore une fois ces tests
salivaires ne sont valables et ne sont
valides et que pour les personnes qui
ont des symptômes
tout simplement parce que là la quantité
de virus que l'on que l'on retrouve les
plus importantes et donc un pacte la
qualité du la qualité du test donc pour
les personnes malades
le ca va effectivement amélioré les
choses pour les personnes qui n'ont
aucun symptôme
c'est vrai qu'on va rester dans une dans
un encombrement
si je peux parler ainsi l'encombrement
actuelle est inutile
un mot sur le flanc blanc qui a été
déclenché dans certains hôpitaux
c'est la prochaine étape en tout cas
c'est là où le curseur se place pour
contrôler cette épidémie absolument mais
quand le plan blanc et déclencher comme
dans mon hôpital par exemple quand le
plan blanc et des tranchées c'est trop
tard c'est avant qu'il aurait fallu
faire quelque chose je parle pas de la
politique des hôpitaux nous ont réagi
aux malades qu'on nous envoie mais c'est
avant que la prévention aurait dû être
importantes et là encore c'est un appel
à la responsabilité de la population
dans son ensemble
il est vrai que porter un masque ou se
tenir à distance des autres c'est
contraignant ça n'est pas forcément
drôle on a envie de faire autre chose
mais c'est le prix à payer pour éviter
des drames en nonne en aval oui donc
vous dites responsabilités tout en
continuant vivre normalement si je puis
dire mais en gardant ses distances hier
le plus oui le plus normalement possible
compte tenu de la contractent merci
beaucoup gens paniquent talent d'avoir
répondu
à nos questions ce soir sur rtl france
alors que de nombreux élus demandent un
moratoire sur le déploiement de la 5g en
france la commission européenne a
demandé hier d'accélérer le pas à tous
ses états membres
a lyon aujourd'hui vous voyez des
associations des collectifs des citoyens
se sont mobilisés contre son déploiement
est ce là une semaine après la tribune
co signée par le maire écologiste de
cette ville là grégory douce et qui s'en
était pris je vous le rappelle au tour
de france le président emmanuel macron
avait dans la foulée renvoyer ces
écologistes au passé lima rosie ce sont
elles qui agite tant les écologistes
français les antennes 5 g avec la clis
du coronavirus leur déploiement a pris
du retard
une situation qui inquiète la commission
européenne qui demande aux états membres
de presser le pas face à la menace de la
concurrence mondiale notamment
asiatiques et américaines mais en france
tous ne partagent pas cet intérêt pour
la nouvelle génération d'antennes
mobiles
certains y voient un risque écologique
ou sanitaires à la star de ces soixante
huit élus qui ont signé le 12 septembre
dernier une tribune dans le jdd appelant
à un moratoire sur le déploiement de la
5g le gouvernement a identifié la 5g
comme un enjeu stratégique pour la
france
cette décision intervient sans étude
d'impact climatique et environnementale
ni aucune consultation publique
préalable
pourtant l'utilité réelle de la 5g est
loin d'être aussi évidente que le
prétendent les opérateurs de téléphonie
mobile où le gouvernement
le gouvernement justifie sa
précipitation au nom d'un prétendu
retard français
pourtant des questions environnementales
sanitaires et démocratiques sont posés
des questionnements qu emmanuel macron a
balayé d'un revers de main à peine 48
heures plus tard
la france va prendre le tournant de la
5g parce que c'est le tournant de
l'innovation et j'entends beaucoup de
voix qui s'élèvent
pour nous expliquer qu'il faudrait
relever la complexité des problèmes
contemporains en revenant à la lampe à
huile
je ne crois pas au modèle amish et je ne
crois pas que le modèle amish permettent
de régler les défis de l'écologie
contemporaine le secrétaire d'état au
numérique cedrico a quant à lui écarté
tout risque sanitaire
tout comme le patron d'orange stéphane
richard sur france inter ce samedi il ya
vingt mille études
vingt mille études dans le monde qui ont
été faites sur les dangers de
l'exposition aux ondes
électromagnétiques n a pas une seule qui
a jamais mis en évidence le moindre fait
avéré sur ce sur ce sujet des arguments
qui ne convainquent pas les opposants
aux nouvelles antennes une manifestation
anti 5 g est d ailleurs prévue samedi
prochain à bruxelles
et voyez à présent les explications de
ian taele larrère il est docteur en
droit social et spécialistes du
numérique cofondateur du site
ok doc point fr on boit régulièrement
dans les débats en france des cons à
l'introduction de nouvelles technologies
des peurs des angoisses qui émergent
on l'avait vu il ya quelques temps avant
avec la 4g on l'avait vu avant avec les
antennes les premières antennes mobiles
donc c'est un débat qui est récurrent
voit aussi avec les compteurs
intelligents les ondes reims après ça
fait beaucoup de peur et ça fait
beaucoup parler et à mon avis le débat
il ya un petit peu instrumentalisés par
des gens qui voudraient un modèle en
décroissance les écologistes parlent des
vidéos qu'on peut télécharger plus vite
que c'est pas nécessaire etc
mais ils oublient vraiment houleux
pendant techniques industrielles à 5 g
ces centrales dans les usines de demain
dans tous les usages dans tous les
services connectés des villes
intelligentes
on aura et on a besoin de la 5g si on
veut prendre le train en marche parce
que sinon les choses se passeront
ailleurs sands et on revient à cette
fusillade hier à marseille devant une
école maternelle dans le 16e
arrondissement un homme d'une trentaine
d'années a d'ailleurs été grièvement
blessé les coups de feu ont éclaté à
proximité d'une école maternelle à 16h20
quelques minutes avant la sortie des
classes les élèves ont dû se réfugier
des tables jusqu'à l'arrivée des
autorités les motifs restent encore
floues l'adjointe à la mairie de
marseille samia ghali a évoqué une
possible dispute familiale
voyez là la réaction des dissidents
délégué du syndicat unité sgp police
malheureusement avec une autre notre
cité phocéenne et sans vouloir faire de
marc faye bashing est connu
effectivement pour la rénovant de compte
maintenant on a quand même passé un cap
et je le précise parce que je sais la
nuit mhra que de nuit on a eu une année
sombre effectivement il ya peu pas
souvent de deux témoins une personne
présente donc en pleine journée
il est 16 heures il nicolas côté les
parents on sera lourde et l'année 4,6
alors temps pour partir en week-end
en russie vladimir poutine répond aux
accusations de donald trump en meeting
hier dans le minnesota le président
américain a accusé la russie d'avoir
volé de la technologie à
l'administration obama
des informations qui concernent les
fameux missiles supersoniques que moscou
à d'ailleurs lancé avec succès en
décembre dernier les états unis ont fait
de même quelques mois plus tard en
juillet et avec des résultats moins
probants dans ce domaine c'est bien là
la russie qui al'avantage selon de
nombreux experts voyez les précisions
d'antoine claireaux à moscou le
président russe s'est exprimé sur ce
sujet alors qu'il décorait herberth
efremov un ingénieur qui a participé à
la conception de fusée par le passé et
entendre vladimir poutine moscou dispose
désormais d'un énorme avantage militaire
sur ses rivaux à savoir des missiles
hypersonique pour la première fois dans
l'histoire récente la russie possède les
types d'armes les plus modernes qui
surpasse de plusieurs fois par leur
force leur puissance leur vitesse qui
est très important et leur précision
toutes celles qui existaient existe
aujourd'hui personnes dans le monde
entier n'a de telles armes en tout cas
pour l'instant muet lors d'un meeting
l'année dernière donald trump a prétendu
que si les russes en était là
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'ils avaient
volé des informations aux états unis du
temps de l'administration obama
vous savez ils ont un missile dessus
père du père hypersonique je l'appelle
super du père parce qu'il va cinq fois
plus vite qu'un missile normal d'accord
nous en avons 1 qui va plus vite que ça
mais la russie a eu cette information de
l'administration obama
la russie a volé cette information vous
savez la russie a obtenu ces
informations
puis ils l'ont construit mais à présent
on en a un beau coup beaucoup plus
rapide que celui là celui là c'est comme
un incident les considérer comme un
missile en l'avenir poutine va répondu
d'une certaine façon la mettant que
c'était bien grâce aux états unis que la
russie possède ses armements à l'heure
actuelle mais c'est plutôt la
conséquence d'une décision prise par
washington il ya près de 19 ans qui en
est à l'origine
le retrait des etats-unis du traité anti
missiles balistiques en 2002 a forcé la
russie a lancé l'élaboration de barney
personnic nous avons dû créer ses armes
en réponse au déploiement par les états
unis d'un système de défense antimissile
stratégique qui à terme auraient été
capables de neutraliser de mettre à zéro
l'ensemble de notre potentiel nucléaire
voilà donc ce que peut causer le retrait
d'un traité de contrôle des armements
stratégiques
à noter que washington est sortie début
2010 9 du traité sur les forces
nucléaires rapporte intermédiaires et ne
manifeste pas tellement sa volonté de
prolonger le traité new start de
contrôle des armements nucléaires
stratégiques qui lui arrive à échéance
en 2021 avec les conséquences que cela
peut avoir
autre enjeu de la présidentielle aux
états unis le nom du prochain juge de la
cour suprême qui est au centre d'une
bataille acharnée entre donald trump et
joe biden après le décès de ruth bader
ginsburg donald trump a appelé les
sénateurs à nommer son délai son
successeur il veut imposer à tout prix
son candidat avant l'élection du 3
novembre prochain fatoumata bakili et
hélène masquelier ses bulletins de santé
étaient suivis par les démocrates qui
craignent désormais que donald trump
s'empresse de nommer celle ou celui
appelé à lui succéder
avec la mort de ruth bader ginsburg
cette question est désormais au coeur de
la bataille politique que se livrent les
deux candidats à la présidentielle
amérique
annie pour joe biden pas question de
laisser son rival à la maison blanche
nommé un nouveau juge à quelques
semaines de l'élection
il n'y a aucun doute à avoir
les électeurs doivent choisir le
président et ce dernier a le devoir de
choisir le type de justice qui sera
examiné pour le sénat c'est la position
qui avait été adoptée en 2016
quand il restait dix mois à attendre
avant la présidentielle
c'est la position que le sénat américain
doit désormais avoir mais donald trump
n'entend pas laisser passer une telle
opportunité
malmenés dans les derniers sondages il
compte bien nommer un juge à la cour
suprême avant la présidentielle
son objectif est clair s'assurer du
soutien des électeurs de la droite
religieuse en nommant un juge
conservateur de préférence opposée à
l'avortement est favorable au port
d'armes et le milliardaire a semble-t-il
déjà un nom en tête
j'ai même dit que je m'étais peut-être
cruz parmi les candidats à la cour
suprême vous savez pourquoi je les fais
vous savez pourquoi je les fais parce
que je voulais être sûr d'avoir
quelqu'un sur la liste nous avions
environ 45 personnes incroyables les
plus intelligents les meilleurs la crème
de la crème
quelques jours avant sa mort russe bader
ginsburg avait confié ses dernières
volontés à sa petite fille ne pas être
remplacés temps qu'un nouveau président
n'aurait pas prêter serment que le
prochain locataire de la maison blanche
soit républicain ou démocrate
une chose est sûre le dernier mot
reviendra aux sénateurs selon la
constitution américaine une fois le
choix du président arrêté c'est au sénat
d'avaliser le choix du candidat
décédé à à 87 ans ruth bader ginsburg
est l une des icônes les plus choyés par
les démocrates deuxième femme de
l'histoire des états unis a siégé au
sein de la cour suprême elle il ya
défendu sans relâche l'égalité des sexes
hier soir plusieurs personnes se sont
réunies devant
la cour suprême justement pour me rendre
un dernier hommage elle a pris la
défense des personnes privées de leurs
droits et marginalisés et a tenu compte
de leur point de vue lorsqu'elle a rendu
des décisions
sa vie a été honorée et sa mémoire est
une bénédiction
je suis venu ici parce que je pense que
rbg représente tout ce que l'amérique
devrait défendre
elle représente la liberté de choix et
le respect de la science et des autres
personnes indépendamment de leur sexe de
leur origine ethnique de leur couleur de
peau de religion et je pense qu'en tant
qu'américains nous avons la
responsabilité de poursuivre cette
mission
nous sommes ici pour montrer notre
respect et pour être avec d'autres
personnes qui se sentent comme nous et
qui souffrent en ce moment et qui ont
peur des dommages potentiels que
pourrait subir le pays si ce siège et
prix occuper de manière inappropriée
dans les deux semaines qui précèdent
l'élection et voyez à présent les enjeux
de ce poste à la cour suprême avec
pierre guerlain il est professeur de
civilisation américaine à paris 10 donc
c'est une femme qui est extraordinaire
parce que elle a toujours lutté pour
l'égalité entre tous et ce qui se passe
maintenant c'est que les républicains au
sénat bloque récit pitt et son
remplacement avant donc l'élection du 3
novembre les candidats de trump
probablement seront très très à droite
et il a déjà eu la possibilité de nommer
deux juges suprêmes ce qui est énorme
pour n'importe quel président avec un
troisième s'assurerait une majorité
ultraconservatrice de 6 à 3 c'est à dire
que pendant peut-être trente années
puisque les juges qui l'a nommé sont
relativement jeune il y aurait une cour
suprême qui a joué un rôle politique
énorme aux états unis qui serait le mot
conservateur et peu approprié qui sera
hyper réactionnaire
allez on termine par ces manifestations
en thaïlande où la jeunesse est
mobilisée contre le pouvoir du roi à
bangkok la capitale vous le voyez
plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'étudiants qui sont toujours rassemblés
près de l'ancien palais royal les
manifestations doivent durer 48 heures
depuis fin juin ces manifestations sont
devenues quotidiennes dans le pays les
protestataires réclament davantage de
démocratie la dissolution du parlement
et la démission du premier ministre
mais ils n'appellent pas à
l'insurrection écoutez le gouvernement
actuel a organisé un coup d'état et a
retiré les droits du peuple
la raison pour laquelle je suis ici
c'est que je veux récupérer ses droits
il y a une chance que le gouvernement
réussisse à satisfaire nos demandes mais
il faudra attendre de voir si elle se
concrétisera
si les manifestants sont toujours
déterminé à corriger la constitution
alors le gouvernement ne pourra pas les
ignorer pour toujours et c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de votre fidélité on se
retrouve dans 30 minutes rester avec
nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en pleine crise du coroner virus après
avoir constaté l'incapacité d'une union
européenne a manifesté la moindre
solidarité envers des etam l'europe
une fois de plus est en crise la montée
en puissance de la chine dans le
commerce mondial a évidemment réduit le
poids de l'euro il faut y ajouter la
fragmentation de la zone et son
incapacité